named Wilson paul krugman and russell
simmons but first a panel on ethics and
book reviewing includes Christopher
Hitchens Francine prose and sam
Tanenhaus this is about 90 minutes
thanks John this started out because I
did a survey years ago in 1988 on on the
ethics of book reviewing and at the time
when I wrote a note to the audience and
to our membership I wrote to the
respondent to accuse the surveys drafter
of being an idiot I say you're right but
not for the reason you think I plan to
leave future surveys to large
institutions with career bureaucrats and
charming duck ponds well I forgot that
plan never to do a survey again and when
we started talking this year about
changes in the business and the
development of the blogosphere and all
of that
we all thought at NBCC that it was time
to ask some questions again in order we
hoped to have comparative data we
decided to ask about 10 or 12 questions
that we had asked back in 1988
unfortunately since we're not
statisticians or social scientists and
we're book critics we blew it we
included in other category we didn't
have before so things don't quite line
up but as far as I'm concerned all of
this is just you know an extended
anecdote and the numbers are fun but the
real idea is to get us thinking about
issues what I want to do since we do
have a quite a crowd and we're hoping to
go to one o'clock at least some of us if
the the energy is in the room but we'll
break briefly at 12:30 so everybody can
go where they need to go because the
ever advertisement was for 12:30 I
thought the most effective way to do
this is to first start with a little bit
of performance art instead of my
introducing everybody I'll have everyone
introduce himself or herself as if they
were writing a good critical ID for
review you know eg Christopher Hitchens
as the future author of God is still not
great or something like that and then I
will take a couple of minutes just to
toss the questions in the air I'm not
going to give you results because I
would eat too much
too much time but I think I'd like the
questions in the air I'm then going to
ask everybody on the panel to talk for
about five minutes
toward this subject individual questions
or whether the whole thing is a bunch of
malarkey and we shouldn't worry about
ethics and book reviewing and then we'll
open it up to conversation so I'd like
to start just by having the panel
introduce itself Chris Hitchens here I
write books for the Atlantic Monthly I'm
Francine prose I'm a novelist and
sometime book reviewer John Leonard I
write new books column every month for
Harper's and and longer reviews for the
New York Review of Books in the nation
I'm David Yulin I'm the book editor the
Los Angeles Times I write for the paper
before that I was a freelance reviewer
for 20 years god save me i'm sam
Tanenhaus I'm the editor of the New York
Times Book Review so hardly any editing
needed
I've objective introductions so we had a
thirty to a question survey just so you
have a little bit of numbers of the
beginning who somehow amazingly thanks
to Survey Monkey we got 356 responses to
these 32 questions and don'ting leave
because the software has this other
category which people immediately ran to
not wanting to answer yes no we're not
sure we have 1836 comments
you won't hear all of them today the
only question that absolutely all the
356 people responded to is are you an
NBC C member so everyone was able to
answer that question I'm going to just
mention a couple of things here the the
survey obviously saw it clear-cut
answers this other category in
particular the invitation to comments
invited people to immediately go there
and talk about the nuance nuances so
probably a thousand of these 1800
comments are it depends how can you even
ask or something like that
but we still have some numbers and I'll
try to put some of them out if those
issues come come up both from the old
survey and the new one but here are the
questions I'll try and just real them
off real fast should a book review
editor assign a book to a casual
acquaintance of the author eg someone
the reviewer may have met at a writing
conference party or on a panel but who
is not a close friend should a book
review editor assign a book to a friend
of the author should a book review
editor assign a book on subject a to a
reviewer who has also written a book on
subject a or a subject extremely close
to that is it right for book review
editors to allow reviewers to request a
particular book even though that
practice occasionally leads to back
scratching and attempted setups is the
book review is it the book review
editors obligation to question a
perspective excuse-me reviewer about
potential conflicts of interest rather
than the reviewers to raise the subject
is it ethical for a reviewer to decline
to review a book he has already accepted
for review on the ground that he didn't
like the book and doesn't want to say
negative things in print should anyone
mentioned in the acknowledgments of a
book be barred from reviewing it should
authorize for the particular house be
permitted to review other books
published by that house should a writer
be allowed to review the book of someone
who shares the same literary agent
that's a question in which the response
has changed enormous Lee from 20 years
ago should a person who has written an
unpaid blurb for a book be allowed to
write a fuller review of the book should
an editor ever assign a book to a
reviewer who is known to hold aesthetic
political or literary views contrary to
those of the author should an editor
ever assign a book to a reviewer who is
known to hold aesthetic political or
literary views similar to the authors is
it ever
ethical to review a book without reading
the entire book that that has stayed
fairly consistent although it's a trick
question because it says ever so if you
think it ever is okay then your answer
should be yes but most people actually
change that and they thought is it
generally ethical to review a book
anyway should literary blogs adhere to
the same rules of ethics whatever the
consensus may turn out to be on them as
newspaper book review sections
this is beginning of the new questions a
lot of those questions were on the
earlier survey - should literary
journals serious popular magazines eg
the Atlantic and so-called opinion
magazines eg the nation adhere to the
same rules of ethics whatever the
consensus may turn out to be on them as
newspaper book review sections should a
literary blogger review the book of
another literary blogger - whose blog
she or he links I remember I wrote that
he or she so I guess Survey Monkey is a
woman and sort of reverse that alright
should freelance book critics request
only those books from publishers that
they're likely to review or judge for an
award or is it okay for freelancers to
request a much larger number of books I
wrote that terrible question which is a
disjunction which does not allow a
yes-or-no answer and so a lot of people
immediately fled to other if you think
it's okay for freelancers to request
more books than they can review a judge
is it okay for them to sell whichever
ones they don't want to keep I don't
know if the strength person is here I
understand they have an anniversary we
asked that question in honor of the
anniversary is it okay to assign a book
by author a to review or be when author
a has served as a major source for B in
a book that B has already published
known to us as the Woodward on tenet
question is it okay for a book review
editor in deciding which books to review
to favor books by writers who also
review regularly for that book section
nice a nice new question should a
reviewer read other reviews of a book
before reviewing it is it okay for a
reviewer to regularly review books from
the same one or two favorite publishing
houses is it okay for a reviewer to
repeatedly review books by the same
author over years and even decades you
may notice the shift from should - is it
okay a lot of people were upset by that
it's really just elegant variation but
there are some issues there should a
reviewer sometimes be allowed to crib
from his or her past reviews in writing
about an author years later is it that
we're almost done is it ever acceptable
for a reviewer not to say what she or he
really thinks about a book
are the ethics of book reviewing in the
United States and England significantly
different now here I have to say we're
so glad hitch is here because this was
an amazing result I just have to tell
you not sure 73 percent so if he has
become an American citizen if you don't
know the answer either we're completely
lost it is ok is it ok and these are a
little technical is it ok for a book
review section to both feature and
author through a podcast meant to
promote traffic to that book section
site and also review the author's book
at more or less the same time given some
of these questions came from our
membership by the way and I don't
understand them myself given that some
companies paper post blog vert eyes
review me pay bloggers for reviews of
products and services should any book
reviews commissioned in that way be
identified as arising out of commissions
should a review of a book be linked to
its Amazon page or any other site that
sells the book is a book review that
exists exclusively as an mp3 or other
type digital audio file less objective
than a traditional print review because
of its delivery elements eg tone of
voice is it okay for a newspaper or
magazine to review books by current or
former staff members and then this is
the last question is it okay for a
newspaper book section or magazine to
ignore self-published books that are
submitted eg iUniverse type books so
that was the whole survey I'm not gonna
ask everybody maybe in alphabetical
order I guess to talk for about five
minutes each on this subject or any
questions that interest them so I guess
Christopher would be first well I've
never been wanted to be an editor of
anything so I'm not really sure if I can
answer any of those questions Evan
there's not the dilemmas I've faced and
I know nothing about podcasting or
webcasting so I can narrow it down to
the gutter ethics of Fleet Street in
which I was brought up where the motto
if I remember was a it's just an only
line but it's from the it's from the
book of Job and it says
it says oh that mine enemy would write a
book because then you know you'll get
him one of these days I once opened a
copy of the London Spectator to find
myself being reviewed little book I'd
done on the sculpture of the Parthenon I
was reviewed by a gentleman called
Arkansas remember his name Noah Malcolm
a fellow of Peterhouse Cambridge who
started by accusing me of plagiarism and
sort of worked his way on from there
very anti non filer hellenic and non
file addictions review and i thought ok
mr. malcolm dr. malcolm if you insist
that's all very well one day you'll read
book and so it came to pass Guardian The
Guardian called me up one day in
Washington it was must have been ten
eleven years yet later but the memory
was still so fresh and they said you
busy this week unless I'm incredibly
busy they said we just want you to
review a book so I can't take on
anything this week and say well it's a
pity can you suggest anyone else to
review no Malcolm's book on what I said
hold on just what justice
just a second I said no it's okay sling
it over I set up with it it was not it
was about Bosnia one of the best books
I've ever read I had no choice but to
say so it still rankles that I had to do
I remember being commiserated with by
one of Sam's predecessors at the New
York Times Book Review when I published
my first collection of essays called
prepare for the worst and in the London
Times Literary Supplement it was
reviewed by Conor Cruz O'Brien who was
the subject of a very critical chapter
or one of the essays so collected in
other words and he gave it quite a quite
tough review and including mentioning
that he was mentioned in the book and
including correcting me on what he
thought were a couple of points of
interpretation and this process of Samsa
that's absolutely terrible you must feel
ghastly I mean how can they do that to
you they they take the book of yours and
they give it to someone who's criticized
in the book I mean that would that would
never happen to you and I said wouldn't
know that's why in some ways the tls is
in war this was a long time ago the tls
is somewhat more readable than the New
York Times Book Review because it
doesn't have this permanent affectation
of integrity
well there is an unspoken rule that all
books by and about Henry Kissinger are
always given respectful treatment and
usually by people who owe him something
all could be reasonably expected to be
in his debt with everyone else the
degrees of separation the absurd degree
and scope that Colin was just embracing
almost prevent anyone who's qualified in
the book or could be bothered to read it
or be interested in the subject or the
author from having anything to do with
it and that used to show I thought quite
a lot now there are there are very
obvious things I think that you can do
by way of a little diagram I think it
was spy magazine used to actually do it
you could show how some enemy of philip
roth's or friend and so on
and how the cross hatchings of the
blurbs went and all this kind of thing
and it's pretty easy to see that coming
and are nothing to fend it off but I I
have just it isn't it isn't published
yet but I've just reviewed a novel by
Ann McKuen for a novella called Chesil
Beach which he's here to launch I hope
you'll go to whatever event he's having
at this expert I've known for quite a
long time whose work with his work I'm
extremely and intimately familiar an
author who I asked to be the dedicate
she if my new book God is not great it's
consecrated to him the kill so I didn't
ask him for a blood but I wish I had now
and I consider myself the best person
qualified to review on chesil beach for
the Atlantic Monthly and if anyone
doesn't like that they can kiss my ass
and I don't believe anyone would say
there was a quid pro quo involved I
think it would be is done barely boring
and cheap to say that but if anyone
wants to give it a try
bring it on anything and remember the
job citation you'll need it you'll need
it one day let's make a couple of
distinctions if you are if you are new
in the game or you know struggling as a
freelance reviewer you don't have any
choice as to which books are going to
review an editor will determine that the
ethics ethical question then becomes the
editors ethical question I've been on
both sides of this been a literary
editor of The Times Book Review in the
70s and of the nation in the late 90s
and two entirely different operations
two entirely different philosophies have
to apply as Sam can tell you it greater
and more intimate length when you are a
magazine like The Times Book Review
charged basically with looking at
everything that moves in the literary
called
you will you any individual book can get
about seven different approaches to a
review it can no matter what the book is
you can you can assign a reviewer whose
approach will be autobiographical
because they've gone through some of
these experiences themselves will be
journalistic because they have covered
this kind of territory as a story can be
philosophical or intellectual because
they're philosophers on the question and
and and the person that you assign at
that moment will probably be somebody
who will give you a different approach
than the last time you wrote it you had
ran a review on this subject or ran a
review of this author because you want
to mix up your coverage you want to be
different from what you were last week
you don't always want to be predictable
so it's that this is not vagrant this is
a necessary part of the fraud of
cultural journalism with the with the
nation I had every expectation of when I
sent out a book for review of getting a
review that I agreed with it was sent
out many books we wouldn't review
because they had no political context
many books were reviewed because I cared
about them personally and I didn't care
whether the rest of the culture did it
was my job my playpen I did expect to
get back a within a within a framework
somewhere between say I hate I hate to
define the Democratic Party on the right
as as as Bill Clinton but let's say that
what's the safe when Bill Clinton all
the way over to Che Guevara but I didn't
I would not be running somebody to the
right of Bill Clinton I wouldn't ask him
and this was a political magazine you
know it had a right to be intemperate
and had a right to be biased and had a
right to to try to control it and you
still can't control it because reviewers
never do what you told them to do so
those are those are going on the
literary side on the I mean on the
editor side on the on the on the the
writers side I'm an old man I'm 68 years
old
nobody can tell me what to do I review
only those books I want to review and if
I want to review at length I shop around
until somebody will let me review at
length otherwise I review in Harper's
years ago 40 years ago I wrote an
article for a lapsed magazine called
cultural affairs which in which I
interviewed myself as a daily book
critic for the New York Times listing
the questions that most often come up
about the job and the first question was
what do you do when a friend writes a
book and my answer then was try to give
it a favorable review if you if you
don't like the way his mind works why is
he your friend this was this was a
little June but but sort of like
Christopher I will I will say the same
thing who else am I supposed to be
friends with I've been in this business
for 40 years journalists academics and
novelists are the people I become
friends with because they're the only
people I can go to dinner with who won't
talk about movies or real estate I care
about so they become my friends so and
they stand and many of them will stay my
friends and a lot of them won't because
if the books come along and if they
write a book that I don't like I used to
review it because but I reviewed all the
time two or three times a week now if a
friend writes a book that I don't like I
don't review it they know that and some
of them resent it but on the other hand
I became friends or Toni Morrison's has
a friend of the mind there are a whole
bunch of writers out there that I've
reviewed most of their books over the
years I've never met them or I met them
once or twice a cocktail party here
there but I will always review their
books because they were a friend of my
mind right at the beginning and I'm
interested in how they work it out and I
don't and one book to the next made I'm
not in the business of giving a grade
I'm not a grammar school teacher now say
this one's a B that was this D plus and
this one's an A at last
I'm interested in the development the
evolution of this writer I will always
be interested in this writer this writer
I this is the writer I care about so I
will I will review those those people no
matter how intimate I am with them and I
think it's a mistake just as Christopher
suggested it's a mistake not to have me
review these who knows them better I've
read every word you know I pride myself
when I root when I when I review a
writer to have read all of the books and
to try to see what that writers but up
to all of the time and I mess up because
I'm not as smart as you know I you know
I review writers like Richard powers and
I'm not as smart as Richard powers but I
do my best and frankly I think ethics
ethics questions when it comes to book
reviews are such small potatoes when it
comes to the corruptions of the of the
culture at large the way metastatic
capitalism lies to us everybody lies to
us and the book reviews there's no money
in it to begin with and therefore you
can't have serious ethical questions
there are problems that we'll address
and I'll stop but the problems we should
ought to address that you know there
there are I consider unethical for a
book reviewer to be showing off at the
expense of the author and the expense of
the reader I consider performance art
book reviewing a scandal
you've got your responsibilities or
elsewhere and if all you're doing is
making making a spectacle of yourself so
that people will look at you join the
circus and I also consider the people
who read out all kinds of books because
they don't like them if you're if you
care about literary fiction you can't
care about mysteries you can't care
about cyberpunk science fiction you
can't care about this or that these
people are unimaginative narrow
parochial and we should pay no attention
to them and I think we should also worry
about people who bring who bring the
book reviewing any kind of ideologies
I'm a left winger I've always been a
left winger but you know if if I can't
review Nabokov and like it what's the
with me I'm a I'm an idiot as well as
the left winger and and I don't feel
that is necessary but there are people
who make books submit to a litmus test
and I think that is unethical but as for
I'll end with
going back to the question of friends
many of mine lately banned dying and the
fact that I could say something nice
about them in public while they were
still alive makes me think I have a
chance to get into heaven too I'm gonna
answer two of Carlin's questions briefly
and then go on to say why I don't want
to answer any of the others first of all
I do send back books that I don't like
mainly because I think why should I ruin
the life of a innocent first novelist
when they're clearly to meet people out
there who will love this book and should
be helped to find this book which is one
of the functions in the book review
second of all I also review book books
by acquaintances and even friends
as Christopher said I don't feel that it
clouds my objectivity as John said I
feel that I can be an advocate for the
book years ago I was assigned a book by
one up by one of Sam's predecessors of
the book review and it was someone I
knew a guy I knew he wasn't a close
friend he was someone I taught with and
had been at writers conferences with and
I explained I asked if that was a
conflict of interest and the editor said
have you ever had an affair with the guy
not that I remember
go ahead and write the review and I did
but but the reason that I that the whole
question of ethics kind of bothers me is
it seems to me to support a slightly
bogus idea about book reviewing which is
I think not a friend of book reviewing
in general not a friend of literary
culture which is that the book review is
some sort of version of Consumer Reports
or its you know like a peer review panel
of the FDA those are scientific
processes and the consequences are
Rivas that is you know if you run the
car into the wall and all the crash-test
dummies come flying off the car is
dangerous if you give a drug to someone
and they all die et cetera but but book
reviewing is quite a different matter
because matters of opinion matters of
taste all come in and should come in and
don't have no relation finally to
whether you know the writer or whether
you've written this kind of book or so
forth and and they're important and it
seems to me that the primary obligation
of the book reviewer is to write
interestingly about the book that's
that's whether you like the book whether
you're not like whether you don't like
the book that should be your idea I mean
if what's interesting to you and and
also I think that if critics thought
about that there would be a different
kind of criticism I mean that is if
what's interesting to a critic is to set
up a book you know like a beer can in
one's backyard and just shoot at it then
that's sort of interesting that's
interesting to a critic it doesn't
happen to be interesting to me at this
point in my life and I think that the
most unethical thing to do is to write
about a book boringly
it's no friend to the book it's not your
being no friend to the writer and no
friend to reading in general which is
what we all should be doing Thanks
I agree with just about everything the
panelists have said so far first though
I want to say I hope that we at the book
of you have rid ourselves of the stigma
of the permanent affectation of
integrity we also want to be interesting
what we look at first is the reader
something that occurs to me or occurred
to me when Carlin read through those
lists of questions is it all seemed to
be about a transaction between the
reviewer and the author reviewer and the
publisher when everyone here has said as
a critic oneself and I've written
probably far too much criticism from my
own good and everyone else is are you
really thinking of the reader I'm
you're seeing it as a you know not
certainly enough performance art but a
kind of narrative that will engage the
readers interest and I think when we
talk a lot about the ethics of reviewing
we are covertly and sometimes overtly
degrading the principles of criticism
and I that my predecessors have said
that much better than I can so I'll just
leave it at that
a couple of other questions that have
come up we have a review running this
Sunday forgive me if I've got the dates
wrong we closed so earlier I never know
what's coming up for me in my mind for
next Sunday is often two or three weeks
at I think it's this Sunday is Jonathan
Lethem
on Ian McEwan's new novel and when I
approached him we put him through the
New York Times wringer about ethics and
he said which is conflict again and he
said well you know I did once have a
comradely lunch or dinner with Ian
McEwan but I think I can write about him
well and he wrote what I think is one of
the really superb essays we've published
for just the reasons Christopher has
mentioned it and and John and Francine
as well because he grasps the the
meaning of the work at its root he's a
fellow novelist who also has a kind of
theoretical idea about what fiction can
and and can't do he understands him with
the respect that a major practitioner in
the same field has but someone who's
also read very widely and deeply in
literature he's a gorgeous writer
himself who gains if Liam doesn't write
that review who profits from it maybe we
could huddle somewhere in a room that's
is my colleagues and I and say well we
dodged that bullet but it wasn't a
bullet it was a gift that was denied our
readers a couple of other examples we
early on I started the job just a little
over three years ago Jonathan Franzen
sent us a note and he said look I want
to write
something about Alice Monroe I think
this is one of the great living riders
and that's what I'm gonna say so I
thought well now do you not want to hear
what Jonathan Franzen has to say about
Alice Monroe I wanted to see what he had
to say and I think it's one of the great
and really influential pieces we've
published a more recent example we had
Christopher's book God is not great and
Christopher did I hear you say God bless
to someone when we walked and and we
decided we asked ourselves who would be
interesting on this and Mike Kinsley
seemed like a guy who would write about
it in an intelligent lively way partly
because he does know Christopher and so
in the note I sent him I said we I
assume you two were acquainted let's
make that clear somehow in the review
and take it on its own terms
and I didn't hear many complaints about
that review there were objections that
Mike also is an atheist but it seemed to
us at this point with so many books
being written on the topic and so few
with the panache and wit of
Christopher's you want a critic who has
the same panache in which you want a
kind of dual of interesting minds and so
it's a review we're very happy to have
done and the last thing I'll say is not
long into this job I now hold one of my
esteemed colleagues Julie just said
you'll know who your friends are when
you leave this job and I said that's not
a problem I don't have any friends
anyway
so I'm just realizing sitting up here
that I'm faint with hunger so if if this
is noncoherent I apologize as far as the
survey you know I could run through the
questions and say yes no yes no yes no
but I also think that this issue of
ethics is probably overstated or maybe
we're not looking at it from the right
filter from my point of view as an
editor it boils down to a kind of case
by case basis I don't have very many
hard and fast rules the the primary one
in terms of the reviewers that I work
with is disclosed to me first I mean we
also put reviewers through a we asked
them about potential conflicts and I've
had people say you know as far as and I
say no potential conflict is too stupid
so I've had people say I don't know if I
can review a book a certain novel that
cannot publish because Knopf turned down
my last novel and I you know I say fine
that doesn't bother me unless it bothers
you I mean for me the real issue is can
the reviewer write and and well I don't
really believe in objectivity as a
concept so that's the wrong way but that
kind of as objective as I can get can
the reviewer take the book on on its own
terms and create a review that I agree
with what Francine was saying that needs
to be a reading experience a discrete
and wonderful reading experience on its
own that needs to be part of a three
dimensional conversation between the
reviewer the writer of the book under
review and the reader of the review I
think that's a very important point that
it it's not just about the reviewer on
the book but there is a third party in
this and I think that third party is in
many ways the most important party and
does the reviewer have something to say
that is compelling and interesting and
informative and real about what this
book is what this book does and you know
and I think that those questions are not
they don't break down to a survey for me
they're a really individual case-by-case
situation so for instance if you were
signing a review of Don DeLillo it
matters in my view that the reviewer is
familiar with DeLillo's career it
doesn't
thoroughly matter whether the reviewer
has been sympathetic entirely or not but
the reviewer has to know something about
DeLillo it's a lot different than if you
were assigning a review of a first novel
or even of a third novel by a writer
where the novel sort of stands on its
own in terms of the review I also think
it's different if you're assigning a
longer review or a shorter review if
you're assigning an essay essay ich
review then you the assumption or at
least my assumption is that there will
be more career context more of a sense
of placing this writer within a frame
whereas in a six or an 800 word review
it's often all a reviewer can do to
basically assess the book of the book
under question so I want my reviewers to
tell me any potential conflict and then
I'll decide case-by-case I have I do
draw the line and having friends review
friends because I think it gets tricky
and it's a tricky area I'd rather not go
into I don't I don't review my friends
books as a reviewer mostly because I
want them to remain my friends and also
I just feel like it's cleaner not to
have not to have that but as far as
acquaintances go again it depends on the
nature of the acquaintance if it's
somebody you you know you interviewed
ten years ago does that invalidate you
from writing a review I don't think so
unless it's someone you had a strong
reaction to I was given example I won't
say who it is but I was given example of
a writer I wanted to review a book and
then I interviewed this writer and I
also don't necessarily have a problem
with a reviewer who doesn't interview
with the writer and then also reviews
the book again it depends on whether
that reviewer can maintain his sort of
critical distance or critical judgment
but I wanted to review this book and I
interviewed the writer and I'd attested
the writer so much after spending an
hour interviewing him that I couldn't
review the book because I couldn't I
couldn't keep that out so I opted out of
reviewing that book that was before I
was an editor so those things happen I
don't have an issue with with reviewers
saying to me I don't want to review this
book right read part of this book and I
don't want to review it although I also
think that it's the ethical obligation
of the book review to publish negative
reviews I think I don't trust a critical
voice whether in it whether it's a
critics voice or a publication's voice
that isn't willing to be negative
but that said I also don't trust a
publication or critic that you know
where the negativity is gratuitous I
think what Christopher was saying is
really important that even though he
wanted to give that book a bad review he
couldn't because he liked the book he
thought the book was remarkable and I
think that to me is the ultimate ethical
standard can you praise the book even
though you don't want to or can you
criticize the book or take it on even
though you don't want to and that to me
is the real standard and I could talk
more specifically but I'll stop there
again I just want to stress the idea
that it really to me is very much a kind
of case by case sort of situation
depending on the book under review the
review and the editor oh and the other
thing I'll just say one one other thing
I'll say is I also think it's the it's
the role of the book review to
occasionally challenge I've not
challenged champion writers so for
instance last Sunday we put Lydia Davis
on the cover because I think Lydia Davis
is a remarkable short story writer who
has never gotten her due and so I wanted
to put I wanted to put that book on the
cover and give it more play we gave it a
long review we had again we create we've
sort of assigned a career piece using
the new collection as a way of looking
at the career of this writer as a way of
filling what I think is one of the
functions of a book of a newspaper book
review which is to say to our readers
here you ought to be paying attention to
this and that too I think is something
that is ethical in a different way
because we all are part of this
conversation about books and literature
and I think we need to be cognizant of
that and what it means both in terms of
criticizing books and also in terms of
championing them
I am not the designated defender of this
survey I agree with a lot of what's been
and said and I have a mix of you on a
lot of these things but I'm gonna punch
back a little bit from the standpoint of
ethics mattering because I heard some
things that suggested that they do
matter after you get past the original
you know pronouncement that it's okay to
do this and that let's talk about Ian
McEwan as an example since he's come up
several times so today in the times is a
really nasty review of his new novel
that says it's a lousy book by Kakutani
now I thought it was a terrible review
as I think a lot of her reviews are
terrible reviews in other words every
sentence she quoted from McEwan was a
better sentence than any sentence she
wrote herself in the review so it's not
well argued it's not convincing and so
on full of adjectives you know but I
don't think she was thinking well I'm
not sure I should say this um he's a
nice guy I met him at lunch and so on
and one of my concerns when I've
assigned and as a reviewer and so on is
can you write an honest review can you
be honestly negative that's usually the
challenging question if you don't like a
book so I mean Christopher if you read
Ian's book and you actually shared
Kakutani opinion could you say it would
you say it and when you talk about the
reader who loses in this who gains it
seems to me readers do lose when you get
phony reviews from friends that say this
is a great novel when secretly you're
thinking boy this was really
disappointing but I can't say that about
him so I'm just wondering what you all
think about you know the the real
ability to be honest in a negative vein
when there is some kind of connection
and you do care about friendship well if
I think if I was sent a novel by Ian
McEwan and really disliked it I probably
would decide not to reveal I just have
to I wouldn't be able to say if I really
decided I know I wouldn't be able to say
how much I did put it like that I did
give an even dear friend of mine martin
amos an extremely nasty review
but that was because there was so much
unpleasant stuff about me in the book
that review was obviously vetted before
I want to I want to say something about
that it's very simple
not to review a book you don't have to
review every book that comes along even
if it's by your friend or your
acquaintance or whatever it yes you for
for intellectual respectability any
publication and any critic there's got
to have a record of negative reviews if
only so that the reader has a way to
bounce to judge to shade you've got to
establish your reputation the more you
review the easier this is for what you
liked and disliked what your standards
are so that you don't have to start all
over again with every review every 800
review 800 word review say this is what
I care about this is what I don't care
about so you know where I am
you bet you do you so a negative review
can help can help you establish in the
readers mind where you stand in the
culture this is this is fine but at a
certain point you you cease to be or you
should cease to be making your
reputation on the basis of scorchin
slash-and-burn reviewing I no longer
have the taste unless it's in Norman
Podhoretz
I no longer really want to to tear
somebody to shreds and like Francine you
know a book will be will be sent to me
and and I'll look at it I don't like
this and I don't see any reason to tell
people you know a whole bunch of people
but here's a book by somebody you never
heard of and it isn't any good and this
this seems to me to taste like aspirin
but when when a particular thing with it
with a friend comes along you can't lie
you can't say it's a good book when it's
not a good book your only honor is is
your name and your reputation so so keep
silent
or lose the friendship and write them
and write the excoriating review one of
the things we tend to forget is that is
that reviews are written and reviewers
exist in various emotional clouds when
we're reviewing a book we may be infirm
we may be divorcing we may be drunk we
you know we we may be so full of hatred
for the for the world for reasons that
are there that can't be explained or
just depressed and the in comes a book
and we're not being fair to it we've got
a we've got to always consult our own
weather before we send those words out
and there was there was a time in my
life when I was basically killing myself
with alcohol and I was finding in every
book that was sent to me for review
reveries of the sort that fit right in
with the reveries that I was that I was
indulging in and this often had nothing
really to do with the book itself or
what the author intended it had to do
with what I thought I needed and my
self-pity and everything and after
looking at a couple of these things when
they were published I decided to give
books a rest for a while because they
were more important then to be used in
such a in such a way and so I just
stopped and then I sobered up and then I
felt I could at least you know do you
think against yourself as a review or
you you say okay what are my
preconceptions here that may interfere
and and once you've gone that the next
part of the process is is to say okay if
I really like this book or I think the
argument is important how can I get the
reader to see this and that becomes your
active craft that becomes the
interesting thing that the Francine
demands of a review okay the you mount
an argument it's an act of seduction and
but you want somehow to recreate in the
reader the experiences that you had when
you read the book and so friends
acquaintances enemies don't have nearly
as much
to do with it or ought to have nearly as
much to do with it and you're honest
encounter with that book at that time to
the best of your ability to report to
the reader what happened to you when you
were lost in it for years I wrote
reviews for the New York Observer and my
editor there was the wonderful Adam
Begley who knew that he could send me
books that would really irritate me for
extra literary reasons and that I would
go kind of nuts and just write these
trashing hilarious reviews and you know
books about the life-saving wonders of
plastic surgery and so forth that I
would just you know and nothing is more
fun I mean I have to say than writing
that kind of review because often you
can use these books to mock themselves
all you have to do is quote but but
finally it just began to seem sort of
sickening to me and and I couldn't do it
anymore I mean there are many ways of
writing a negative review every so often
you really feel you have to have one
have to write one I just reviewed for
The Times that new Jim Christ novel a
book I didn't particularly like but I
think he's a wonderful writer and
there's a way of saying that and doing
that without just wanting for some
strange reason to destroy the writer
destroy the book and destroy the
person's career some advice or even war
about this when he want to praise
faintly for example you know if it's
Hollywood you probably know this
someone's done a ghastly film and you
say you must be very proud well the
other thing as you say you've done it
again with with book has to be a little
more some of that even more suggests
that you say mr. crisis many admirers
will at this point you know that would
really sting if someone say that about
me
does it I don't know if any of the
review editors want to speak to this but
it seems to me one reality of the
business is that when people do turn
bound turn back books because they don't
want to say something negative often
they don't get reassigned and you know
that old notion that any publicity is
good publicity any coverage is
worthwhile coverage that does that
bother anybody that if you turn down a
book maybe that book by the first time
novelist won't get a review yeah I sent
back the historian that book and because
I thought it was the worst thing that I
had ever read in my entire life and it
became a mega bestseller so I don't it
doesn't seem to me that I did that much
harm I think it's I think it depends on
the book you know for a variety of
reasons one is that you know these
things are time sensitive especially in
newspapers and so I think sometimes that
small first novel might not get
reassigned you know if it's a case where
you know as an example we had it wasn't
because of the book what it wasn't
because the book wasn't like but for
instance we have a review had a review
assigned of Tom sega's book 1967 and
then there was a the reviewer there was
an issue and wasn't able to review the
book so we had to reassign the book but
as a consequence we'll be a little late
on that later than we would have liked
on that review so sometimes that happens
I think it's all but I think you know
the other sort of unspoken part of this
and this panel isn't about this so we'll
stay off of the subject is that for most
book review sections these paper book
review sections space has always at a
premium anyway so you're always it's
always sort of a kind of triage
situation where you're trying to recover
what you can and you know that there are
always going to be many worthy books
that aren't going to get covered that
you'd very much like to cover but
there's just simply no way to do it
because you do you you're always
fighting to balance how many books you
can cover with what's the depth of the
coverage you're gonna give them and
and I think that that's a really sort of
important balance to keep in mind it's
not just merely about the quantity of
books but also about the quality of
criticism I'm gonna open this up Dakota
to the audience as we move into that
last half hour where people can choose
to stay or not I did want to say that
this though I mean all five of our
panelists our authors have been authors
and our critical community in the NBC C
split on that question of turning back
books it was actually one of the few
exact splits 34% 34% you should always
do it negative or positive or no it's
okay not to do a negative review I find
it interesting that probably everybody
on this panel thinks you can say
whatever you want to say however nasty
it might be about government officials
of business officials politicians and so
on but there's a kind of desire that we
be kindly to authors and not really
always call a spade a spade I mean I
want to say something for the critical
site I don't understand why it's not
okay to look at a book and say this is
really terrible and maybe even in
stinging language when it's okay to
criticize almost every other part of
society now one thing that does happen
to all of us at newspapers I think I'll
make this my last question before
opening it up is that some of us find
ourselves working for institutions that
have rules of ethics we don't
necessarily share that don't make sense
to us when I came in I remember Mike
Leavitt oz was the times book editor I
remember him telling me no one can ever
request a book for review at the times
it's absolutely prohibited we decide who
reviews a book and as you see that was a
question on the survey can the people
who have been in that situation speak to
how do you handle that you don't really
agree with the code of ethics of the New
York Times or the LA Times as it applies
to book reviewing but it's there let's
let's go to that let's go back to this
business of of being kinder to authors
than we are to to politicians to
businessmen or whatever there is a
there's a difference in kind and a
difference in quality between the people
who have power and the people who don't
and some innocent person who's published
even a bad book has no power to wound
the culture to wound you to wound
anybody else but but somebody who is in
government somebody who has runs a big
business somebody who owns a newspaper
somebody somebody like that has a lot of
power in the community and you you have
to speak to them you have to say that
they're lying you have to make sure they
don't get away with anything because
these people run the world
the first novelist does not run the
world I think you were obliged at a
certain point if it's a if it's a Philip
Roth or whatever somewhere along the
line you say this I didn't like this
book I didn't like that book or whatever
but that's a reputation he's he's
established too he's he's not vulnerable
he's not out there without a shell on
he's not somebody who spent all those
years you know writing a book and then
sending it naked out into the world
having having been antisocial all that
time and misses his child and you stomp
on it you know it's so what big you
these people these people do not deserve
the rudeness of a culture that has
tendency to reduce anyway jump in on
this on this one point at the risk of
sounding like the hard-ass on the panel
I don't I don't I hope I didn't give the
impression that I think we should be
nice to writers of books that don't
merit niceness and I think that it's
important again it comes back to the
importance of negative reviews not
because it's important to be negative
but because it's important to tell the
truth about what you think about a book
I think that's true from a writer's
point of view I think that's true from
an editorial point of view what I draw
the line that is I don't want to I don't
think it's ethical to write or publish a
hit piece but I do think it's ethical to
write and publish negative reviews even
negative reviews of writers early in
their career if that's the review that
you get and I do think it's essential in
terms of the readers again trusting the
publication that we assign books to
reviewers who will say what they think
and who will wear their enthusiasms Pro
or their enthusiasms or their anti
enthusiasms on their sleeve and won't
pull their punches I mean this is
something that I say all the time to
people don't pull your punches and I
think but I also think people review
sometimes reviewers tend to pull their
punches in terms of positive criticism
as well they feel that it's somehow
anti-intellectual to be effusive or to
be emotional and I think that book
reviewing again in terms of what
Francine was saying in terms of the
Shapley essay notion of book reviewing
it wrote it relies on the kind of on the
engagement and enthusiasm pro or con of
the critic that's what I'm looking for
more than more than I'm looking for a
positive or a negative review ad well
first of all sure we publish them very
very tough reviews and we do it when we
think they're good that is to say that
the argument seems to stand up to
scrutiny and the writing is good it
doesn't mean we agree with them but we
publish them and reviewers of course
should not feel constrained in what they
say or how they say it also as far as
books being turned back and going out to
other reviewers we are reassigned
whenever we can you know something that
I think were some of us are obliquely
getting that maybe two points one is
there's very different ways in which one
can review I speak as much as a reviewer
as a book review editor fiction versus
nonfiction because nonfiction you can
kind of write about the subject and
engage with it that way this is one
reason that the and this is some of the
corollary point that the authors who
most often get slighted in the sense of
not being reviewed because we think
we're sparing them our first novelists
or authors of their first short story
collections and if you know how the
section high edit works we have a bi
book reviewing standards by the centers
of contemporary journalism a fairly
large staff of six or eight people
sometimes one or two more who are
actually reading fairly deep
into the galley before deciding whether
to assign it and they tend to be pretty
tough our reviewers tend to be tougher
and we think here is a first novelist
here's a novel that seems like there's
some promise here but what happens when
it gets hammered and this is what John
is talking about you have really nobody
from nowhere who's worked very hard and
written a book whose only claim to very
small celebrity will be that someone
eviscerated it in the pages of the New
York Times Book Review we would rather
not do that now to the credit of our
readers and I don't know how what
experience other people have had here
I've had it both as an author and as a
book of II read readers often read
criticism very differently from the way
we inside the business do for one thing
they tend to think almost any book
review is favorable simply because the
book is being reviewed and the author's
name is endlessly repeated I remember in
a book of mine came out and it was it
was well review but there were some
dissenting voices and I was shocked to
hear myself complimented on those
favorable reviews and I thought well
maybe readers know something we don't
which is not only that it's not
essential to be parsing every phrase in
a review because the fact is most of us
ours of Grub Street are still that is to
say we're not writing dr. Johnson or
Coleridge's prose though we you know
we'd like to but also that readers know
a review is one person's opinion and the
bylines we talked about and that week of
it at my section I'm sure David does too
we got X to review why most readers
don't even notice unless it's a huge
name they really don't notice they
notice that the Times Book Review
reviewed something and in fact
publishers know this too
because one will often see ads that
quote from the New York Times Book
Review it'll be a line of praise it will
say New York Times Book Review and it
won't say the reviewer with someone who
seems hugely consequential to us it's
because most readers don't look at it
that way and I say more power to them
you know here we live in what Roth calls
the ego sphere and each one of us
carries his own with him or her I think
readers in their way know better and so
that's good I think it it also keeps us
from taking ourselves too seriously
a couple of our panelists have to go
it's a little bit past 12:30 some of
them can stay I'm sure some of you can
stay let's take a little break for just
a minute anybody who needs to go please
go and then the rest of us can keep
talking and I want to open up to
questions conversation from the audience
so so and we have a microphone in the
audience so please say who you are and
direct your questions to somebody in
particular and our first question is hi
my name is Lizzie score NIC and I'm a
freelance reviewer and I'm glad the 3 of
you are left on the panel because I
think you had the most interesting
things to say about this topic but well
I was interested on the question of
reviewing one's friends and enemies
because it seems like the reader
actually has a very different
perspective than what the three of you
as reviewers would say and that I think
your average reader the worry when a
friend or enemy is reviewed obviously is
the question of influence but it seems
like what you're saying and what we saw
in Christopher Hitchins story is that
it's not a question of not seeing the
book clearly it's a question of whether
or not you might want to publish the
review it seemed like what Christopher
was saying was not that he couldn't see
the book of his enemy clearly but that
who's called by the fact that he liked
the book is that the case do you really
think there's no
of actual influence and if there is a
question of influence is that a bad
thing
can I answer that well first of all I
just have to say that I don't really
understand what clearly means in this
situation I mean because there's so many
to make it a question of whether you
know the reviewer whether you know the
author and there's so many other factors
I mean the two for example the two most
positive reviews that I've written
recently for The Times Book Review one
was a book that I read while I was
waiting I in a doctor's office you know
endless weights for I'd broken my arm
and the other was a book that I'd read
on a transatlantic airplane flight now
those are situations in which I'm
grateful for distraction I have no you
know I'll prick - pretty much love what
and in fact I love those books I mean
I've since looked at the books I was
right to love them but when the
assigning editor called me should I have
said you know where I read those books I
was in a doctor's office and an airplane
flight I mean so much influences ones
judgment that the question of our
acquaintance with the writer it's only a
little tiny percentage of that so so I
again the whole question of objectivity
seems odd to me because it's a its
opinion it's finally it's just once
taste one's mood once as John said once
moment in life all those things factor
in other question yeah
hi I'm Levi yeah sure there was a
blogger favoritism is only one ethical
issue one I actually had hoped to direct
this to sam Tanenhaus
I remember when Henry Kissinger reviewed
a book about Dean Acheson and you know I
I think I was not alone in feeling I was
a sort of thinly veiled defense of his
own career as Secretary of State and you
know is that another form of this
self-serving review is is that another
form of ethical consideration yes I
think that gets back to what John was
saying about performance art reviewing
and I think that's not just true in the
case of someone like Kissinger it also
has to do with any reviewer who has an
axe to grind that
not generated by the book under review
you know I mean maybe the book under
review gives you an axe to grind pro or
con but it but not but I don't I I'm not
interested in the reviewer who comes in
with a soapbox and then stands on it and
uses the book as an excuse to wax
philosophical or otherwise about a
variety of subjects you know you have to
you have to do you think this way though
if you're if you're if you're a
journalistic Enterprise such as The
Times Book Review you want to raise some
eyebrows stir some crap do all of this
and that every once in a while it seems
to me to be journalistically justifiable
to throw something like this out I'm not
gonna pick up Henry Kissinger and say oh
boy Henry Kissinger I really want to
know what he thinks about whatever it is
I know what he thinks and he thinks only
about Henry Kissinger in fact I left the
New York Times back in 1983 after when I
was the daily book critic because they'd
started betting my my my newspaper
reviews politically and a particular
example was Henry Kissinger's memoirs
Murrow week oh I went to it every editor
in the in the in the place and I
basically just you know he said it I
have to say this this is off the subject
but Henry Kissinger and his first volume
memoirs wrote that he'd spent one
sleepless night in all his years in
public service and that was the evening
before his secret visit to China when he
they were opening up the channel to
China and and my crime so far as the New
York Times was concerned was to suggest
that he should have spent many more
sleepless nights and but but you know
Kissinger everyone everyone said why do
you want to get I mean I remember my
back in my day you get Eugene McCarthy
well you were gonna get Eugene McCarthy
being disdainful of everybody else but
you were gonna get people to read it and
and that was just showbiz John before we
go to the next question can you just
explain what you mean by performance art
criticism because I've always loved your
reviewing and I think of you as a
performance art critic I mean of every
ten metaphors in one of your sentences I
think
absolutely soar and that's the highest
percentage I know of anybody but do you
mean instead of telling people what the
book is about and giving them your
experience of the book so this appears
like you and I read I read the reviews
that they chill up on the online that
you write carlin about you always make
it a point to quote to quote the writer
you're reviewing you always make it a
point we we always try to ensure what
the metaphors that that I use or you use
should somehow come out of the metaphors
that we've been exposed to by the book
you begin to think like the like if you
admire the writer like like the writer
so that it's a it's suggestive and they
ought to be in the service of the of the
book the the best in the business ever
for doing this was Isaiah Berlin where
he sometimes couldn't tell when he was
writing about Hudson or something like
that where Hertz installing took over
this this gives a kind of momentum to
the to the review and also
persuasiveness to the review I'm not
saying that you shouldn't write well
when you're right or I'm saying that it
should not be at the expense of the
writer and the and the book that you
were doing that everybody sees only you
and not and not the writer because
because quite frankly it is a parasitic
business reviewing
without the genius we are nothing we're
nothing but we are writing that genius
we are symbiotic on it and somebody had
to do a lot of work so that we do less
amount of work and we we find our honor
in various ways which we've discussed of
this panel but let's not misunderstand
where the importance is the the the
importance and the responsibility to the
reader and to the writer is to make sure
that we keep who's first first thanks
yeah we have a question in the back yeah
want to know about negative reviews to
me as a reader they're more enjoyable to
read my sense is that they may sell more
papers for you but on the flip side
what about the the publishing
advertisers what kind of pressure might
you get for the reviews not to be quite
so negative so if you could talk to both
those sides
well since publishers don't advertise in
regional book review sections I feel
absolutely no pressure whatsoever I
wouldn't if they you know I believe in
the church state wall I wanted as high
as possible I don't talk to the
advertising side I mean not I'm sure
they're perfectly nice but I wouldn't
know and I don't want to know it so it's
an irrelevant question I think if you're
thinking about advertising when you're
assigning or editing reviews then you
should get another job
next question John in the back and then
maybe up here in the front under
question what happens when a hit piece
is written and you're not sure that it's
a hit piece and it runs and the damage
is done this is question basically I
guess for John and for Carlin I'm sorry
David and Carlin and and John when
something has happened and you're not
sure that it has an unethical dimension
to it until it's run and someone informs
you well you know there's a background
to this what do you do do you go and
assign a new review or what's what's the
what sort of the damage control let me
let me speak to this from from from from
scars that glow in the dark after many
many years I'm not talking about the one
that before you published I'm talking
about the ones that you do publish that
it turns out that you should have known
better you have no choice but but to
fess up and in public and as quickly and
as prominently as possible
because you've done real damage to your
credibility in in in a particularly
Grievous instance and might in my tenure
at The Times Book Review in the early
70s I got a telephone call from the
lawyer the hotshot lawyer many of you
may remember if you're as old as I am
Melvin belli and Melvin belli I wanted
to review a book that somebody I can't
remember the name of the
I know Charles something had written on
judges in America and had written it was
an attack on on judges and Nolan Bella I
suggested plausibly to me that he had a
lot of opinions on judges and that this
book was a wonderful jumping off point
for telling stories about judges etc etc
so I commissioned that and in came a
reviewed which it was quite entertaining
and unfavorable to the book under review
and I published it and I then got a call
from a reporter I believe saying that
that he had heard that that all of this
was a joke that that that Bell and I was
a friend of the author of this book that
the author of the book had posed as Bell
I with Bell eyes permission and had
conned me into getting his own book
assigned to him and he'd written the
review himself and I had published it
and I I said good
there's no I'm good at talking my way
out of lots of things but there was no
way to talk my way out of that and I
made a few inquiries and everybody
thought it was very humorous but me I
didn't think it was humorous so I wrote
I devoted the back page of The Times
Book Review the following issue to a
column titled suckered and and described
the whole thing and and said that you
know none of this is funny
none of it is funny the whole bunch of
people have been cheated so you could
have your club' yucks
and as a result you know everybody that
seems to be associated with this all I
can do is say deliver I'll never have
anything to do with them again but
that's insufficient because because
everybody's been cheated and you know
when you when you find out if you find
out in time obviously you don't you
don't run it but again your your your
recourse we're not this is not this is I
repeat again when I said it's not life
and death it's not it's it's it's
it's you don't cut off people's hands
because they behave badly of this you
just say I'll never use that person as a
reviewer again I'll never trust that
person in my in my tenure at The Times
Book Review you could never trust a poet
now it's now it's coming out all poets
had ulterior agendas all poets had mixed
motives poets would wait for decades to
get somebody who'd stolen their
girlfriend yeah poets the person who was
the chairman of the department at the
university was gonna get it you know
Christopher Christopher holding a grudge
all poets behave badly and I had to get
out of town I had to you know hire Helen
Bend lure up and up in Boston to
basically bet every single poetry that
came in because I knew I would trust her
and I wouldn't trust anybody else to at
least tell me where the bodies were
buried you never know where all the
bodies are buried
but when you find out one is buried
you've got to make it clear you've got
to fess up we've got and you've got to
apologize to everybody as quickly as
possible
she John now you're getting into the
spirit of the survey it's like I tell a
quick case of mine a long time ago where
I assigned the review of a biography of
Michener to somebody who had worked for
him on one of his teams of researchers
and I thought I had vetted the guy and
you know that the the relationship was
fine and he knew about mission and all
that and then it was a Friday and the
our book section was ready to run and I
learned that he had sued missioner and
and actually you know won money from
Mishnah and he hadn't told me this and
all of that
so luckily in those days we didn't have
much advance time and I was able to put
the beans of Egypt mane as I remember by
Carolyn shoot which would not have been
a cover review on the cover so you know
that that was savable but the other
thing that always sticks in my mind is
setting up a review with with uh
actually a poet their leading black poet
a good guy liked them and all of that we
set it all up ready to go and I said to
him well I guess we're in great shape
unless you were married to her and he
said I thought you knew that
I said no how am I gonna know that am i
tracking your sex life like everyday and
but luckily we had to back out of that
but this is why one of the best answers
on this survey which happened in our
earlier survey too was that both
reviewer should feel an obligation to
raise a potential conflict of interest
reviewers just shouldn't leave it to the
editor because editors are too busy
often to remember to ask and so on right
and I think that's the key point is that
it's it's a mutual obligation editors
only know what reviewers are gonna tell
them I mean unless you know the reviewer
really really really well which only
happens in a rare instance so you can
ask the question but if you don't get
the answer you're at the mercy but I
agree just you know with everyone that
if if you get caught in that situation
you have no choice but to just come
clean instantly and and I think in the
case if someone trashes a book out of
nefarious purposes probably to reassign
the book yeah you've been very patient
in the first row there sorry about that
risk
my name is Annabelle I'm the host I
edited a review a book twice a month and
my I'm looking for more advice on how to
filter out I had a conversation with a
professor about a specific author who's
amazing like you know I went there but I
hated her book and she's actually here
today and I'm probably gonna end up
meeting her and I'm reviewing her book
out in the next show how do you filter
out how do you you know filter out a lot
of the voices in your head you know and
stay objective you know in true the book
you know I I was having a lot of issues
with the characters but how much of that
is what you're hearing from external
forces and what
anybody I don't know I mean I think it's
hard to filter out you know suppose the
character reminds you of somebody you
know in your life and you despise it's
very hard to not but but but I think
finally your obligation is to try and
figure out what the writer is trying to
do and how well the writer has succeeded
in whatever he or she is trying to do
and that has nothing to do with the
characters and also something in general
I'd like to raise which is one of the
things that bothers me most about
contemporary book reviewing and
contemporary reading which is this kind
of nutty idea that that if you don't
like the characters in a book you don't
like the book and that's you know how
would you read crime and punishment for
example I mean you know the guy kills
two old ladies for no reason so I think
that that has to be filtered out too and
just say you know what was she trying to
do what were her aims did she accomplish
it and and in that sense you can take
yourself out to it out of it and on a
more practical level I never read
anything about a book that I'm writing
about and I expect reviewers to do that
too I never read any other reviews I
don't read profiles I don't read the
publicity materials I don't read jacket
copy
I don't read anything I just read the
book and I try and stay away from it and
if it's a book that I'm really
interested in for instance I recently
reviewed the Michael Shaymin novel and I
was curious about what other people were
saying about that so I saved those
pieces and then after my piece ran I
read them but I think it's it's really
difficult to keep the voices out of your
head if any way and if you actively are
inviting the voices into your head then
it's impossible
quick quick piece of info to the
question should a reviewer read other
reviews of a book before reviewing it 40
percent said no 17 percent or so said
yes it's okay have that feeling that you
don't want all of that in your head I my
quick answer would be just stick to the
book review the book because there is so
much [ __ ] in the air pre-publication
reviews Kakutani killing books in their
crib and so on and I know there are
people around the country you know they
think that oh well [ __ ] you Tony killed
it we don't have to worry about it it's
dead in the country because now instead
of her review running in one place is
running in 30
places with all the demise of book
reviews we'll talk about on Sunday so
you know book review editor's you know
who have the privilege of getting all of
these books in their offices you should
go to the book read the first 20 pages
get a sense of what what it is keep
going and forget about the rest other
questions we've got about five minutes
yeah I used to review books on a very
regular basis in the 80s and 90s for
example for the daily newspaper in
Louisville back when the Binghams owned
it and in those days I was given 350
words to cover a book and I learned
pretty quickly the craft of a telling
the reader what the book was about be
you know giving some idea of of how it
was structure you know how it different
from other books on the subject
there was nonfiction and see you know
giving my opinion as to its value now
one thing I've noticed about booker
newspaper book reviewing in the last 10
years is that in order to compete with
the internet you have increasingly had a
format come up where the pictures get
larger and larger and wider and wider a
margin sphere in the text and the type
gets larger and larger now back in the
50s it's John Leonard would remember the
New York Times on a weekday basis had a
column which simply listed the books
published that day or that week and gave
a two line description of each one you
know even even listening the titles of
paperback reprints down at the bottom
and then on Sunday you would go and you
know cut say spend a page and half for
two pages or a page or half a page you
know covering these books and you know
if you had a book a picture there if it
was not a photo if the author will be
you know a picture that did not
necessarily dominate at the expense of
the case you bring it to a question just
because we only have a couple of minutes
left and I don't want to exclude
somebody if they have a question now the
question being posed here is how does a
book editor balance the need to balance
need to present a review long enough to
give the reader only an idea of what the
book is about whether the reviewer
regards the book is worthwhile with this
this idea that
that page itself as a as a visual thing
you know his significant see the
Washington Post booklet world nowadays
one of their full-page reviews is
perceptibly shorter than one of the old
half page NY TBR reviews from the 70s
and as a result though the length of the
review almost mandates sometimes that
the reviewer can do no more than almost
state the jacket just to say okay size
matters and it's a size matters question
you know the the misery that graphics is
brought into the world of book reviewing
this is infinite and the depth is we
drown in it I I can tell you is a is a
I've been a television critic for New
York magazine for 23 years and and the
the page the number of words that I get
to a page in New York magazine has gone
from twelve hundred and fifty to 750 and
and to to no purpose that I can see
except to accommodate teasers and
pictures that are bigger than they need
to be except what gets lost as the
consumer guide which I'm supposedly
providing with books it's this it's the
same but it's more it's a little more
complicated
everybody everybody wants to compete for
everybody else's attention and they and
and and newspapers and magazines feel
that they the only way they can do that
is through graphics not through better
writing or better choices or better by
lines or whatever they do it they try to
do it through graphics and and through
teasing through telling you what the
people what the piece says before you
read it all of the stuff and however
even at the Times Book Review which
unlike the LA Times gets a significant
amount of book advertising it's going
way down it's going way down so the the
real threat to the book reviewing is the
amount of print period that a newspaper
is willing to devote to to book
reviewing medium in mind in my day at
the Times Book Review we would we would
70-page issues almost every week and you
know it was just and it was the same the
New Yorker at that time in the 60s and
70s you know we think we think of that
that is the glory days of John McPhee
giving you everything you never wanted
to know about oranges and three separate
excerpts but the fact of the matter is
that William Shawn had an enormous
amount of space because he had an
enormous amount of advertising and we
don't have that advertising anymore and
we don't have it for books and and so
they never advertised outside in Boston
or Los Angeles they just San Francisco
they simply show cago they simply
wouldn't do it but now they're not even
advertising and in the times they're
finding better places to put their but
they think better places to put their
money and that's the route that's I'm
sorry to say is the real is the real
threat if you look at the you lose
you've lost about a third of the words
almost everywhere yes you're right about
about a third of the words but the pages
lost but you never see loss is there
another question the last question over
there when an author writes a letter to
the editor and says that review really
sucked
is there an ethical piece there do you
always print it never print it does the
reviewer get to respond I know different
publications handled differently if I'd
love to hear your thoughts we we rarely
published letters to the other only
because of space and in fact we're in
the process of I think we're gonna start
running the letters to the editor column
on the website because we have the space
but for me I mean sort of touches back
on what John was saying for me I given
limited space I I would give the space
to a review rather than to a letter
unless it's a letter unless something an
egregious has occurred in which case we
need to come clean about it
my general policy wouldn't be to let the
reviewer respond only because I feel
like it starts a conversation that I'm
not sure
or benefits anyone and I think the real
question to is what is the author
you know if the author and we get these
letters all the time if it's just as
simply this review sucked and they
didn't understand how great my book was
okay I understand that I've been there
if it's something where they say this
review was wrong or unethical or there's
a conflict of interest here that you
missed then you know that bears
investigation beyond simply publishing
the letter and having some kind of
response to it you know we would then
sort of talk to the author or the person
who sent the letter and find out what it
is exactly that they're talking about
and then we'd look into it and see
whether there was merit - and if there's
merit to it we'd have to do something
about it but it's a long roundabout way
of answering your question something
important here it's almost always a
mistake for the author to write that
letter and it never looks good and if
the if the magazine in question actually
allows the reviewer to respond it's
going to look worse I remember vividly
once alfred kaizen taking grave
exception to something that Joan Didion
had written in The Times Book Review in
my tenure I can't remember what it was
but he went on and on and on and hide in
the highest possible dudgeon basically
saying she was a young whippersnapper
and you know I had no right to
volleyball and it was our occasion I
think I felt I had to run the letter but
I also felt that I had to allow did he
and the chance to respond and she did
and what we ran was we ran this long
letter from al vacation and then it says
Joan Didion replies oh come off it
Alfred we guess who won that
the whippersnapper rose the one quick
comment just on the shorter reviews
about how ridiculous this is in
newspapers then we can break in my own
case we had sort of endlessly dwindling
reviews until they were down then our
daily reviews till about 200 words and
then my legendary editor-in-chief Jean
Roberts said to me these reviews aren't
worth [ __ ] I said yeah well those are
your people who are making them not
worth [ __ ] they keep pressing it down so
why don't we just get rid of them I said
what could I have that space to put it
together into at least one more review
because I agreed there weren't worth
anything and that happened but sometimes
upper editors and newspapers that are
not even conscious that their own
processes are creating the crap that
they then don't like in their own paper
thank you everybody we're going to put
out the results of this survey within
the next week or so some of you are NBCC
members we want to figure out a way that
you can get in to all the comments as I
said 1,800 comments fascinating stuff
it's a very funny group lots of witty
material so we'll get you into that
survey and we'll announce it and again
thanks to the panelists good discussion